I just spent 10 days in the hospital because of a doctor who inserted a stint in my liver and hit my pancreas.
Oh no, that's terrible.
With causing acute pancreatitis, acute pancreatitis of anybody's head, that is the most painful thing.
Oh my goodness, it's really bad and it can lead to very bad complications.
You need to be hospitalized, you need to deal with antibiotics, you just have to do
and there's nothing else you could do with that, it's very dangerous.
So I'm very sorry for this person.
I'm now back home but weigh 20 pounds more because of all the fluids they gave me in the hospital.
It's miserable. How do I get this water retention to go away?
They told me that I would pee it out eventually, but that hasn't happened yet.
Can you give me tips?
So the water, when you retain water like this, is extracellular.
You need it's outside of the cells, in the extracellular spaces.
And the only way to remove it from your body is to get it into the lymph system.
And then remember, it goes into the lymph system and then it gets carried to the
venous system and then it gets deposited into urine and through the kidneys and you get rid of it.
So I would agree with the doctor, that's the only way to get it out, but to get it into the
lymph system as fast as you can is to move. You have to exercise, you have to move, you have to
contract your muscles, you have to wiggle, you have to shake. So the action of movement like
out of vibration plate would help you move lymph. We have some blog posts, lymphatic congestion
and moving lymph. There are some holyopaths for lymph.
Professional formulas makes a lymph stem product that people have found to be helpful,
but motion is the key. That's going to be the absolute key is getting some motion.